Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's March 23, 2023, and we're here in
ActInf Livestream 53.1.
Welcome to the active inference
institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning, and
practicing applied active inference.
This is a recorded and an archived live
stream, so please provide us with
feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams.
Head over to Active Inference.org to
learn more about the institute and
learning groups and projects.
We're here in Active Stream 53.1 and we
are discussing a dyad of papers.
We are discussing Snakes and Ladders in
Paleoanthropology by Hector, Karl and
Michael.
Welcome, Karl.
And we're discussing to copy or not to
copy with Hector and Michael.
Previously in 53.0, we, dean and I
provided some background and context on
these papers.
And today in 53.1 1st, we will all say
hello.
Then we will feature a presentation by
Michael Walker.
And following the presentation, we'll
have a discussion and see where it goes.
So with no further ado, we will all say
hello.
The non authors first, then the authors
concluding with Michael and leading into
the presentation.
So I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California, and it was a great fun and
learning experience to work on the dot
zero.
So I'm really excited to continue in the
dot one today to Dean.
Dean: Thanks, Daniel.
I'm Dean.
I'm here in Calgary.
I guess the only thing I want to just
highlight today is the fact that it's
32323.
And I love that bouncing back and forth
between those two quantities.
So I'm really excited.
And I will pass this to Hector.
Hector: Okay.
Hello, I'm Hector Manrique, and I will
just summarize what brought me here.
Basically, I graduated in psychology.
That was in Spain, and then I did my PhD
in psychobiology.
So I came to learn the biological basis
of behavior.
Then I recycled into a comparative
psychology.
When I joined the Max Planck Institute
for Evolutionary Anthropology in
Lepstick, I was lucky that I could work
with Joseph Kai under his supervision.
And then I had the opportunity to work
with the four species of grade eight.
And after that, I came to know Michael in
a conference on human evolution.
And we have been working together ever
since.
So we are now good friends and also
colleagues.
And that's it, basically.
Daniel: Thank you, Hector and Karl, if
you'd like to say hello, please.
Karl: So, my name is Karl Friston.
I'm a professor of neuroscience at
University College London and a colleague
of our main speakers today, who I've
never seen in person, but now at least I
have seen you, virtually.
They're very nice to meet you.
Daniel: Great.
Thank you, Karl.
Michael, the floor is yours.
Michael: Michael, I'm very pleased to say
hello to Karl, whom I've not yet met
personally, but we are now meeting
visually, virtually.
I'm a retired professor at the University
of Murphy in Spain.
I'm getting rather ancient I shall be 82
years old tomorrow.
But anyway, that doesn't stop me from
digging up Neanderthal skeletons and even
earlier things here in Spain.
I'm very pleased to be presenting this.
It's a case of the dog that didn't bark
in the night.
So whenever you want me to begin, I can
begin.
Daniel: Daniel yes, the slide is up and
it is all you.
Michael: Well, this is really a paper
which we have out on syrup in an earlier
version.
It's now been modified for a different
journal to the one that was originally
intended.
But the presentation is in order to make
a complicated subject fairly simple to
comprehend.
I call it Snakes and Ladders because
stuff appears, disappears and reappears
throughout human evolution over the past
at least 2 million years, if not before.
And the question is, why is there not a
continuous trajectory?
Let's move on to the next one.
Daniel right.
The traditional view is the received
wisdom is looking at what
paleoanthropology can tell us from the
outside.
And there are two basic methodologies,
one based on geology and Darwinism, which
gives us one view of what it is all about
and another view down on the bottom right
is all based on what modern people do and
what modern apes do.
And it's all by so called analogy.
Let's move on to the next one.
Both of these have drawbacks.
I won't go into this in detail.
You're welcome to take these slides away
provided you don't publish them because
they do include some material drawn from
other sources which I haven't
acknowledged formally.
But the drawbacks to Darwinism is really
the difficulty of being able to prove
anything in the past by in its own
terms.
Okay, we can accept it as being a valid
way of explaining natural phenomena and
evolution.
The drawback to using modern analogies is
the spatiotemporal incompetence,
incommensurability with regard to the
regular irregularities and irregular
regularities of which things appear,
disappear and reappear throughout the
Pleistocene record and indeed prehistory
in general.
Let's move on to the next one.
So instead of looking at it from the
outside, let's look at it from the
inside.
And this has an advantage of
commensurability and compatibility at the
same time with the gradual evolution of
and within species by natural selection
and at the same time with the documented
behavior of organis hormone.
Well, this is from Karl's and his
colleagues latest book.
I'm sure you all know it.
So let's move on to the next one.
Right.
In the 1960s, some archaeologists were
certainly reflecting, including some
Cambridge friends of mine, on the
ostensive presence of irregular
regularities and regular irregularities
in the archaeological record.
And a well known one is the Case of the
Wheel.
Wheels were used for action in Central
Asia and the Middle East from about 5000
years ago.
They were invented separately in
Mesoamerica just over 2000 years ago.
They weren't used for any kind of
practical purpose, but just for moving
effigies statues and toys around.
And this seems to have been completely
independent inventions.
Okay, so let's say that surprising
enactment with stuff was the exception in
early humans.
Just see if I can I'm getting a little
bit tied up with two screens here because
I'm working on my own screen.
At the same time, cognitive surprises
were probably disregarded in general
because surprising spontaneous enactment
with stuff distracted attention away from
daily routines.
If we go back 2 million years ago, when
homophobic appears from the earlier
bipedal humans or human ancestors, we
begin to see the establishment of the
Guinness homo, especially in Africa.
And I'm sure that spontaneous enactment
with stuff certainly occurred innumerable
times without gaining any foothold as
technological or cultural, if you like,
communal behavioral traditions passed
down for generation generation, because
this is unlikely.
If we take a period, let's say, from 2
million years ago, even one, even to half
a million years ago, that's one and a
half million years.
That's 60,000 generations.
If you consider one generation as lasting
25 years, most unlikely that things could
be handed down on father the son over
60,000 generations.
So let's take a different take on this.
Let's go back to looking at it from the
inside, from considerations of the free
energy principle and active inference.
It follows that active inference
underpins biological behavior that has
exploratory or epistemic and exploitative
or pragmatic aspects sensitive
respectively to ambiguity and risk
enabling epistemic and ambiguity
resolving responses to support pragmatic,
reward seeking ones.
And therefore it is not implausible that
the snakes and ladders appearance,
disappearance and reappearance of stuff
over, let's say, the past 2 million
years, is the existence of organis owe to
no more than the extreme rarity with
which unorthodox epistemic exploration of
possibly advantageous opportunities in
the human influence resulted from
incipient, albeit imperceptibly, evolving
neurobiological propensities in brains or
hierarchical mechanistic minds to
generate exploitative pragmatic attention
via active inference to cognitive
surprises from untoward behavioral
incidents which weren't expressed more
onto the next one.
So let's forget about let's move on to
the next one.
Daniel, let's forget about this.
How do I get from here to there?
How do I get from a lump of rock to,
let's say, a hand axe by spontaneous
inactive?
What could provoke this?
Okay, let's move on.
Next slide.
I excavated a site.
I am excavating.
The site almost a million years old,
which has one hand axe remains of burning
lots of small stone tools.
You can see some burnt ones on the bottom
left, but then this is the dog that
didn't bark.
Why are there no more hand axe?
Why do we only have one big lodge
bifacially shaped cutting tool, the hand
axe and hundreds of tiny little tools?
People don't ask that question.
Let's move on to the next one.
They explain it away.
People really didn't bother with cutting
up big animals.
They didn't need big cutting tools.
Well, that's one way of looking at it.
Prove it.
People lost stuff and so there should be
more of these around.
But there's only one.
Well, prove that there's only one because
people took them away and used them
elsewhere.
Move that.
The problem is these so called
interpretations only explain stuff away.
Could it well have been a Valentine gift
or not?
Next slide.
So let's get back to Snakes and Ladders.
We have fire at the site there agent too
many sites with fire either.
And again, the general assumption is that
there was continuity once trouble with
moving my other screen.
Just a moment.
How can I move this on?
Excuse me a moment.
My eyesight isn't all that good these
days.
No, that's not doing it.
Excuse me 1 minute.
It's not bad.
So we have the file, as I just mentioned
and I don't believe that suddenly fire
was brought to humans or invented and
then passed on from father to son.
Nor do I believe, as we'll see in the
next slide, that this was done along with
an expansion can we have the next one,
Daniel, please?
Of these early Homo erectus moving from
Africa outwards, carrying a hand axe,
carrying little embers and spreading the
good news.
No, next slide.
Don't think it worked like that.
Stuff couldn't have been passed on over
all that period of time, over all that
space.
This is not commensurable with modern
human or modern ape behavior.
Let's move on to the next one, Daniel.
So how do we begin?
We begin by bashing stone enactment with
stuff.
And that started over 3 million years
ago.
We know that.
Next one, please.
And then we have another problem, which
is that there is almost exponential
increase in stuff, artifacts made by
people, and yet the brain, as we know
from fossil evidence, does not follow
that trajectory, which is the red one.
The brain increases and gradually
flattens out at the same time as the
number of stuff that people make
increases or almost exponentially.
Let's have the next one.
So here we have another problem to try
and solve.
And one possibility which was pointed out
by the late Professor Philip Tobias is
that as the brain increases, we see in
the Paleoanthropological record an
increase in the variation in the volume
of the brain, suggesting perhaps that
there is some relaxation of selection
pressure as Homo evolved.
And we have the next that's a point which
is worth bearing in mind.
So let's think about another way of how
all this may or may not have happened.
A methodological perspective grounded in
fundamental biological and physical
relationships gives us a postimonious
prosaic deflationary account.
All these appearances, disappearances and
reappearances of behavior outcomes and so
called skills.
Now, Professor Nicholas Timbergen, who
was a professor of zoology at Oxford and
got a Nobel Prize, was fascinated with
four questions.
Let's have the next slide and see what
those are.
He wanted to know how we can relate
evolution at four different levels that
of ontogeny and that of the mechanisms,
the causation, that of phylogeny and that
of adaptation or survival value.
And these are related diacronically and
synchronically, as one can see from this
little diagram into also what might call
proximate and ultimate explanatory
approaches if we look at the problem in
hand.
Let's have the next slide, Daniel.
We can see that here we have in the
diatronic aspects paleolithic behavior in
general in the synchronic one stuff
appearing at different times in the top
right.
As far as ontogeny is concerned, we have
something which I'll mention later on,
but we need to make a big deal of it that
we know that there was a lack of
adolescent growth split and a relatively
small brain in Homo erectus one and a
half million years ago compared with
ours, about two thirds the size of ours.
When we think of mechanisms here we come
to looking at it from the inside.
We have the matter of awareness involving
active inference, MathStream, flea energy
principle and variation of flea energy.
And we have what happens at the
neurophysiological level allowing a
complexity of behavior between hand and
stuff, hand and stone in this case, or
stones.
We have to involve matters such as
working memory, long term memory,
perspective memory and indeed
constructive memory.
So how does all this tie into Phylogen?
Here we have a Snakes and Ladder model
based on the empirical evidence from the
past and we have survival value that
clearly existed because Homo erectus
eventually gave rise to us.
Next slide please.
So let's get back to Snakes and Ladders.
Here we have the man looking at the lock
and saying how the hell do I get this
handax out of it?
And now the next one.
And in the same way with the next slide
we have the Snakes and Ladders, a game of
pure chance and of random outcomes.
But next slide please.
We are not dealing with completely random
outcomes.
There's a big difference between, on the
one hand, a spatiotemporal Snakes and
Ladders game of chance as if throws of a
dice alone thought about appearances,
disappearances and reappearances
behavioral phenomena unrelated to
responses of the hierarchical mechanistic
minds of earlier homo and on the other
hand a snakes.
And that is analogy for regular
irregularities and irregular regularities
in the behavioral record owing to
individual idiosyncratic or an orthodox
activity and the receptivity to it or not
of an observing hierarchical mechanistic
mind, whether that's an onlooker, a
bystander or that even the self same man
making the woman making the hand axe in
this case.
Okay, let's move on to the next one.
And here we begin to see that the
heterogeneous composition of a picture of
appearances by chance alone,
disappearances by chance alone,
reappearances by chance alone renders it
useless as a model for making predictions
that can be compared or contrasted with
archaeological findings of early paradigm
science.
Whereas our preferred model, by focusing
on the information, theoretic and
energetic constraints on biological
neurobiological and psychosocial
evolution, affords us a picture that lets
us consider whether the model's focus
could offer a rational interpretation of
the material record.
And in particular of the uneven
distribution across the old world things
like Stonehand axes and evidence of the
tending of fire or even visiting caves.
Things that chimpanzees and gorillas
don't do.
Between 2 million and let's say 200,000
in this case, 80,000 generations.
Okay, let's move on very quickly.
And the rest of it in fact, you're
welcome to read for yourselves rather
than have me read it out to you because
basically you can take this away or copy
it or download it.
What we are arguing is that by about a
million years ago adaptive evolution was
underway of cerebral human
neurobiological propensities that support
prospective and constructive memory in
making artifacts or working with stuff,
doing unusual unorthodox things together
with short term working memory including
that of the hands haptic working memory,
long term working memory and long term
procedural and episodic memory.
Those propensities were phylogenetic
outcomes of existential ontogenetic
programs adapted through natural
selection for satisfying the bioenergetic
requirements of organisms, organis in
particular.
So here we have the basis of our argument
that in a small band of communicatively
challenged Homo erectus one member
spontaneous enactment often went
unregarded.
Disregarded it was regarded as useless,
pointless and unhelpful to gathering the
food requirements needed for surviving
from day to day.
And we can refer the matter to the free
energy principle applied to ecological
niche construction variation on
neuroethology, to use Professor Fisson's
phrase, whereby selection of adaptive
action volcanisms involves their
assessment of the alternatives in terms
of the expected variation of free energy
expressed as the combination of epistemic
and pragmatic affordance.
So these early individuals a million and
a half years ago, who experienced
cognitive surprises, to say prediction
errors about effective variation of the
energy, were unlikely to introduce novel
behavior, whether affected or seen by
them, that could gain.
A foothold in their community before
those communicative skills had developed
in some groups that widened their social
scope for active influence and involved
by natural selection within a shared
framework of adaptive prior beliefs
favoring alignment of common expectations
and joint activities that affected their
ecological niche.
Well, that's the basis of our argument.
Of course.
It's no more, as it were, falsifiable or
refutable within the terms of the data
from the past than the alternatives that
I began with.
But at least it makes rational, coherent
sense and fits in with the Darwinist view
of evolution of species and within
species by natural selection.
It is a more prosaic and deflationary
argument than the ones that people,
archaeologists and anthropologists like
to use and which I began with.
So you can take this away and read it,
read it carefully.
What we're arguing is that by a million
years ago sorry, can you move on Daniel.
And again so let's just stick with this.
I think we can go through this rather
quickly, move on to the next one.
Right, let's go back to a million and a
half years ago.
Let's look at this stuff.
We know there's a skeleton about a kid
only nine years old, according to
Professor Christopher, dean of University
College, professor of Dental Anatomy and
he studied the teeth.
And whilst at one time this individual
had the same height as myself, I'm about
short about 1 meter 57.
Nevertheless, although he had our adult
size, he was only a child at nine years
old and his skull had almost certainly
stopped growing.
It was only two thirds or less than the
size of ours.
But these people were clearly making hand
axes and lighting fires or at least
carrying fire around from time to time
and visiting caves.
We know there was one in South Africa
bonded Cave and doing stuff that is sort
of halfway between what a chimp does and
what our modern primitive peoples are
supposed to have been able to do, let's
say 10,000 or 20,000 years ago during the
last ice age.
But there's a big time difference here.
And when we think about this kid, clearly
he was developing much sooner than we
do.
He became an adult probably before the
age of 15 years old whereas our brains
are not fully formed for at least another
ten years.
So this would have limited have the next
slide.
You can take these away and look at
them.
I don't have to read all this out in
detail to you.
But in short, these people were
precociously developed and therefore much
more limited.
They would be behavior, perhaps more
like, let's say, a modern, I don't know,
four or five year old child of modern
adult height and with a small brain.
Well, they were not doing too badly if
they kept making things making stuff with
their hands, doing things and then
forgetting about them because their main
purpose was to survive and they had to
eat and find something to eat and they
couldn't spend all their time in these
rather than productive activities.
So let's say that let's take the active
inference approach to this and suggest
that from the perspective of the free
energy principle and active inference,
the differences that we're seeing
contextualize the experience dependent
learning and planning and influence on a
small scale.
But they reflect the structural
neurobiological priors that could be
inherited by epigenetic and genetic
processes within the hierarchically
mechanistic minds that were evolving and
which certainly were not the same as
those of modern chimpanzees and gorillas
that don't do all these things that even
our Homo ancestors were doing one and a
half million years ago.
Well, okay, I accept that the absence of
evidence need not imply the evidence of
that absence, but that fails to satisfy
most people or many people, particularly
scientists like ourselves.
Certainly the Darwin's argument had power
has power.
But if we take a look at early human
evolution from the perspective of the
free energy principle our proposal
invokes an overarching methodological
paradigm grounded in an existential
principle fundamental to the evolution of
living organisms and is consistent both
with the long periods of time and the
vast periods of space in the Old world
that we are dealing with, let's say
60,000 or even 80,000 generations across
three continents.
And nevertheless explain allows us to
interpret from the point of view of
natural selection what was going on,
albeit imperceptibly slowly by natural
selection and adaptation.
At least some of the irregular,
regularities and regular irregularities
of phenomena attributable to homo in the
Pleistocene record reflect the kinds of
plausibly anomalous behavioral outcomes
that doubtless occurred often in a snakes
and ladders model of evolution in early
members of our genus, regardless of what
species we want to call their skeletal
remains, whether Neanderthals or merectus
modern Homo whatever.
Okay?
These are plausible outcomes of behavior
by individuals who failed to maintain
orthodox behavioral responses when faced
with cognitive supply zones and who
showed, almost certainly particular
neurobiological propensity to exploring
unorthodox possibilities.
A propensity that's involved further in
humans and in great apes which, unlike
even our very young children, seem unable
to envisage how things might be as well
as how they actually are.
As the Canadian psychologist and
primatologist professor Anne Russen has
written.
And with that, I will end my little
introduction, which I hope will explain a
rather complicated approach to producing
a novel interpretation of how human
behavior was evolving during a very long
period of time and across a very large
period of space on our planet during the
Pleistocene.
Thank you.
Daniel: Thank you, Michael.
Yes, that is the end of the
presentation.
Great.
Thank you for the presentation.
We will now move into discussion, so I'm
going to open up a blank page and then
Hector, Karl and Dean, please feel free
to join.
Dean.
First.
Dean: Of all, Michael, I'm not sure what
your stature is in person, but after that
presentation, you're a giant in my mind
and that's not said out of me needing to
compliment you.
Thank you for the presentation.
I'm curious now because the approach that
Daniel and I took was one of trying to
parameterize a space between the two
papers.
I'm curious now what Hector thinks in
terms of sort of holding up that other
side of this set, in particular with the
paper on to copy or not to copy, and how
we might now sort of gain some depth
perception around things like zone of
about a surprising now that we've had
sort of the introduction with the
presentation that Michael just shared.
Daniel: Hector, feel free to give a first
comment.
Hector: Okay, so you want me to comment
on to copy or not to copy on this one or
how they yeah.
Dean: The zone abound is surprising in
particular given sort of the groundwork
that Michael has just established.
Hector: Okay, perfect.
I would like to start by thanking both
Michael, Andy Clark for this
collaboration, because I think I was
thinking in the Aphorism by Newton, while
attributed to Newton, is not original
from him on the shoulder of giants.
And I think I feel a bit shy here among
this huge intellect and I feel very
privileged too.
So I want to thank them both, Andy Clark
especially because he has been so kind as
to revise our two papers.
I mean, in one he's cohort, but in the
other he revised it and give us very good
indications and advice.
So I'm very grateful because we all know
how busy he is, so he took the time to
help us and I'm very grateful.
And coming back to the papers, the thing
is that Michael came up with this
original idea of explaining this
appearance and disappearance of hand
access in terms of the free energy
principle.
And when we were working on that paper, I
thought that the same argument could
apply naturally to the case of grade
apes.
And the thing that there was this parcel
in grade apes studies when they study
this kind of social transmission or
culture, or cumulative culture, or
cumulative technology.
And what happens is that there are many
reports on chimpanzees being innovative,
meaning innovative like they invent new
things, new behaviors, or new
exploitation of resources by applying new
tools.
So there are many instances of this, but
there is a puzzle here, as there is the
other puzzle with appearance and
disappearances of technology, that there
is no cumulative technology.
So this is a puzzle for me, because if
you have one creature who is able to be
so inventive, how is it possible that it
doesn't accumulate complexity in the
technology?
So the same cognitive machinery, so to
speak, should be able to produce more
complex artifacts, so there is no kind of
accumulation of complexity across
generations.
And that's a big puzzle for me.
So I thought maybe the free energy
principle was useful here too.
So I just made this analogy.
So it's Michael who opened up this new
avenue thanks to the work of Karl.
And I just took advantage to think maybe
it is because new things are too
surprising for gray waves.
So there are features that cannot cope
with high levels of surprise.
If I'm talking too fast or too much, just
tell me.
I think you are following the agreement,
I assume.
Is it okay?
So the idea is that if something that I
observe is too surprising, I have to deal
with this high level of surprise.
And also by reading a paper by Andy
Clark.
The title was Predictive Coding.
It was in behavioral brain sciences, if I
remember correctly.
He talked of one can see very surprising
things if he's able to credit the sensory
information as opposed to the top down
prediction.
And this again helped me to make the
connection.
So maybe the problem is that from the
point of view of the observer of an
innovation, if something is too
surprising, I have to consider if I trust
the sensory information as opposed to the
top down prediction.
And I need to decide, I mean, I'm talking
I need to decide like it was some kind of
animistic thing, but you know what I
mean.
So there is the weighting up of sensory
information and top down prediction.
So my idea was that perhaps what happens
here is that these great apes, when they
observe something new and it's
surprising, they kind of do not credit
it.
So it's like they basically do not
register that because it's a mismatch
with the prediction and for some reason
they are not able to credit essential
information.
And this brings us to the concept of the
zones of bandage surprisals.
So these zones is an imaginary concept.
It's something we use to explain what
happens.
So it's like if you have a wide tone of
boundary, surprisingly, it means that
things that are not in accordance with
your top down predictions, things that
deviate much from these top down
predictions, can be handled because you
are able to bounce surprising.
So you have cognitive mechanisms that
help you to bounce surprising, even when
you are facing huge mismatches with
regard to your expectations, to previous
expectations.
So that will be the main thing here.
So we propose that in gray days there has
not been these changes in the brain that
allow them to bounce surprise, where
things deviate markedly from what they
expect.
Only indeed when they deviate slightly
from what they expect, so they can
accumulate complexity, provided the
things they observe that are new are not
very different from what they expected.
I think I will stop here.
Even I can make more precision.
But that is the basic idea.
I don't know if Michael is in agreement
or he wants to add something, because I
hope I have my limitation with language
too.
So perhaps he can't help me out.
Michael, do you have something to add or
to precise?
Michael: Not really.
Fundamentally, I accept what Hector is
saying.
His idea was certainly novel to me when
he put it forward, that we have to think
about the observers, not merely the
practitioners, because anthropologists
and archaeologists and indeed many people
working in the cognitive and
psychological sciences have tended to put
the emphasis in terms of skills on the
person who performs them and not the
person who or not the observation of
those skills which is so necessary.
Of course.
And I didn't realize this until Hector
pointed out to me, so necessary, of
course, for their transmission to take
hold at all.
And this struck me as being a most
important insight, so obvious that one
wonders why one never thought of it
oneself.
In the same way that one wonders why it
is that so many paleoanthropologists and
archaeologists are more concerned with
this.
Stuff than with why this stuff isn't
there.
These are such obvious problems.
They go back to Sherlock Holmes and so
Arthur Conan Doyle, but we tend to be
obsessed with what we can see and feel
and touch, rather than with what sort of
process might have led to explaining both
presence as and absences at the same
time.
And this is why I find the whole notion
of active inference so important to tie
in with evolution.
It was Professor Christian himself who
enthused me to go back to the lectures
that I used to attend 50 years ago when I
was an undergraduate, that were given by
Nicholas Tinbergen at Oxford.
I would steal away from the lectures of
anatomy given by Sir Wilfred Lagrange
Clark to attend those of Nicholas
Tinbergen and other people.
And I come to realize just how important
Lawrence's and Tinbergens, and, of
course, van Fish von Fish, as Daniel
knows, were, and how worthy they were of
getting, 50 years ago, the Nobel Prize
for physiology or medicine.
50 years later, we're still trying to get
to terms with the significance of their
insights, which shows just how difficult
it is for us to absorb novelty.
But nevertheless, I'm no giant, I'm a
dwarf.
We stand on the shoulders of giants.
Not only Lorenz and Tinbergen, Fish,
Darwin, of course, and going back to
Bayesian in the 18th century, one critic
of our psychic paper said that we were
pomo.
In other words, we were pomo
postmodernist.
No, we go back in a good scientific and
vocal tradition and theoretical tradition
back to the 18th century.
Nothing postmodern about us at all.
I think all of us would reject any
suspicion that we were involved in
postprocessual and postmodernist
argument, unlike many of our colleagues
in what I call the social studies, like
the late Lou Binford, an archaeologist in
America, some note I prefer social
studies to social science, which I think
can at times be something of an opsimal.
I suspect that others will dispute that.
With me, however, I'm no giant, I'm a
dwarf.
It took me all my time to cope with
something we were never taught at school,
matrix algebra, which I had to learn when
I was doing my research on prehistoric
skulls.
And from then, to cope with Bayes theorem
and the approaches or the uses that can
be made of Bayesian mathematical
statistics using matrix theory, which I'm
gradually caught up with, and I can
follow it, but I certainly wouldn't be
capable, unlike Professor Christian of
deriving it.
But I can certainly understand the
significance of something that I think a
lot of our colleagues in the humanities
and social studies simply are not
prepared to confront at all.
I think they prefer much more subjective,
if you like, postmodernist thinking, to
rational scientific analysis.
Well, thank you.
Karl.
Lost the screen.
Can you see me?
I can see you.
Karl: I can see.
Daniel: We see you, Karl.
Michael: My eyesight is no longer quite
as good as it used to be.
So I sometimes tend to huddle over the
computer.
Daniel: It's all good.
It's all good.
Karl, maybe you could come in and share
how this collaboration came to be or from
your view from the inside or however else
you'd like to comment on what we've seen
so far.
Karl: Yes, well, thank you very much for
the opportunity.
I also have to do a lot of huddling
because of my failing eyesight, just to
reiterate what a joy it was to hear that
presentation and Hector's follow up.
So this is, for me, an adventure well
outside my comfort zone.
So I'm here as a passenger spectator and
learning a lot.
I didn't know half of this stuff, even
though I did a lot of biology and a
little bit of evolutionary biology as a
young man.
But this is intriguing and foundational
insights into the way that we are.
So I'm going to make a few comments.
It's going to be more of a stream of
consciousness, but I qualify this again,
but this is completely outside my comfort
zone.
I'm just talking as a layperson here, or
a lay physicist perhaps, and I'll just
make a few observations.
But, Daniel, I'd be particularly
interested in your synthesis because, of
course, you have probably more than any
of us, the broadest oversight from the
evolutionary perspective right through to
the Bayesian mechanics that is entailed
by things like active inference.
Just to forewarn you, I'm going to call
upon you to do the synthesis and to draw
and join the dots that haven't already
been joined, although there's been a lot
of dot joining from what I can see
already.
So the stream of consciousness comes
really from this commitment to ideas that
are certainly not postmodern.
I think I'd probably have to go back to
Plato and certainly sort of get stuck
around the era of helmholtz and the
like.
From a physicist's point of view and
pursuing that, looking at the looking at
this sort of remarkable snakes and
ladders phenomenon through the eyes of a
physicist, it certainly makes complete
sense that if we're looking at a process,
that would be described as a non
equilibrium, steady state that is slowly
evolving.
That could be, if you like, a
mathematical image of the evolutionary
process.
The definitive feature of these non
equilibrium steady states that have a
biological aspect is that they entail a
revisiting of the trajectory to
neighborhoods of certain parts of face
space.
So if I read face space as basically the
state of evolution or what phenotypes are
doing or what is encoded genetically in a
very, very crude, broad level, there can
be no other solution to a particular
trajectory that is apt for describing a
non equilibrium steady state than the
occasional I anteriorant recurrence of
certain states of being literally being
close or revisiting neighborhoods, of
certain regimes of face space.
So the snakes and Ladders image seems to
me a very apt image to actually describe
pullback attractors, which are another
way of articulating these kinds of
dynamics or this kind of kind of dynamics
in the sense that they have this aspect
of recurrence and they have this aspect
of self contained itinerancy which are
the hallmarks of any system, really, that
exists over a substantial period of
time.
It would be interesting to think, can it
be any other way?
And I would submit.
No.
If you have a physical process that is
unfolding at multiple timescales and it
is endowed and can be recognized either
historically or in the moment by being in
certain characteristic states that
literally characterize the system in
question.
So that it can be named, whether it's a
species or whether it's your behavior or
whether it's an artifact or whether it's
a process, then it must be the case that
it has this kind of iterrancy where
things come and go.
So it will be interesting just as a pure
exercise for pure mathematics just to put
things like the Poncara recurrence
theorem into a snakes and ladders format
and vice versa.
Because I think there's something
fundamentally true that has to be the way
that things are.
And I see that in many fields.
And two immediately came to mind.
The first was current notions of not the
spread of ideas or the spread of tools,
but the spread of cancer.
The view that cancer there are two views
of cancer.
There's a sort of 20th century view that
you get one cell in your body, fails to
recognize that it should not be growing
and just keeps on growing and you'll get
these progressive and inevitable growth
of the cancer set of cells and at some
point they will disseminate and seed
themselves around the body.
You get metastases and secondaries and
the like and ultimately, unless it's
cured, then it will destroy the
phenotype.
There's another view which is now
becoming more prevalent, which is a much
more snakes and ladders view.
And this view is that we're all the time
generating little cancer cells but 99.9%
of the of the time they don't get a
foothold.
So that we're in equilibrium, hopefully
on the right side of an equilibrium,
always paying host to little cancer
cells.
It's just that it's very rarely do they
actually establish themselves to the
extent that they can get a foothold and
reproduce to actually produce a tumor or
a neoplastic growth.
And that struck me.
It would be nice to put a snakes and
ladders sort of picture on the way that
that particular biological natural system
is viewed.
And it's certainly very consistent with
current views on cancer.
The other system that seems to comply
with this notion is not, again the spread
of ideas or the spread of tools or
cultural means, but the spread of
viruses.
In epidemiology it's very interesting
that there are certain viruses, for
example, that get a foothold and explode
exponentially.
And we've had, you know, we've just
enjoyed or witnessed an episode of that
with the with the the recent COVID-19
pandemic.
But there are other very similar episodes
that don't get a foothold and they die
out very quickly because they can't
spread.
And I know this personally because we
were looking for data when modeling using
actually exactly the same maths that
underwrites free energy principle, active
inference.
We were modeling the coronavirus crisis
recently and we hope to get some priors
on certain parameters by looking at
legacy historical data.
And it's interesting that there is data
out there on very similar viral
epidemics, but they died out too quickly
to generate enough data to make sense of
so things like MERS, for example, was
recorded, but it went away before it
actually produced enough data to get a
handle on it.
So again, this phenomena of sort of
things repeating themselves, climbing up
the ladder, but then sometimes falling
down a snake very, very quickly.
So you have to wait until the next
occurrence.
Seems to be a fundamental aspects of
ensemble dynamics wherever you see it,
either within the body in terms of
neoplasia or in terms of epidemiology of
spread.
And I use the word spread deliberately
because of that latter perspective on
basically to copy or not to copy.
So if you're copying, then you're in the
game of spreading.
And if you don't copy, then you don't
spend.
So I think just coming back to the
question what is it that determines
whether a particular cognitive surprise
or a novel approach to a way of behaving
or indeed a way of being catches on or
not?
And that dialectic, I think is absolutely
intriguing.
I should just say that all of this
formulation rests very sensitively on a
separation of temporal scales.
In the background, there is always this
separation of scales that you get with
evolution.
And in this particular instance, what we
are talking about is really whether
certain things can survive generationally
in the spirit, I would imagine, of sort
of evo devo and cultural niche
construction.
And then the question then is, okay, at a
fast time scale of interactions between
phenotypes, what's going to make that
sufficiently endemic to be propagated at
a transgenerational timescale?
I think that's a really interesting
question.
Again, it's the kind of question which,
as a neuroscientist, certainly as a
clinician, you are often confronted with
things.
For example, like epilepsy.
What is it, Axel constant that determines
whether a particular epileptic,
surprising, dynamic discharge in a
particular part of the brain can be
propagated and disseminated throughout
the brain to give you a fit or as opposed
to it sort of auto vitiating or quenching
itself because the neighboring cells are
just not interested.
They just don't recognize a particular
pattern and it's inhibited.
And I guess the answer I think we've
already had the answer.
Both Michael and Hector have articulated
it.
But I guess the answer lies in the
mechanics of the spread of ideas and
shared frames of reference and whether it
is too surprising to be incorporated into
your conspecifics or your community or
whether it is learnable and can be
incorporated or absorbed into your
generative models such that it can then
be sped to the next person in the
standard sense of sort of niche
construction.
And Hector mentioned specifically one key
determinant of that, which is Michael,
but it was the ability to change your
mind.
And the ability to change your mind is
absolutely fundamental.
If you want to frame this in an active
inference context, just confronted with a
cognitive surprisal as it has been
articulated, a set of difficult to
explain sensations or sensory evidence,
then there are two ways in which you can
resolve that surprise.
The first way is to change your mind and
to adjust your internal generative models
or do some basic belief updating on the
inside to make sense of this thing.
And that might depend upon some
experience dependent learning over a
suitable timescale so that you're
changing your model, your generative
model of the world to make it more apt to
explain this novel observation or
observation of one of your conspecifics
doing this kind of thing.
The other way is not the perceptual
response, the belief updating on the
inside to make your predictions more like
the sensations.
It's to actually act upon the world, to
make your sensations more like they were
predicted.
So this is foundational inactive
inference.
There's two complementary ways of
minimizing surprisal or prediction
error.
You either change your mind or you change
the thing that you're surprised about at
every level, at every temporal scale.
So just read in terms of whether I am
able to change my mind about witnessing
fire.
There are two ways I can say yes, fire is
a thing and I can then incorporate or
imbibe that into my world model and
become the kind of creature that actually
engages with fire or I can act to put the
fire out and then I don't have to worry
about it.
Both are perfectly appropriate ways of
minimizing surprise.
The difference at a very basic level, the
thing that determines whether I perceive
or act or whether I engage in perceptual
or active inference in the moment to
moment depends exactly on something which
was again mentioned implicitly earlier
on, which is the precision afforded the
sensory evidence relative to your prior
beliefs.
So as a physiologist, if you don't know
this, there are beautiful illustrations
of this.
So if we just forget about the notion at
the moment of sort of long term revisions
or belief updating of our generative
model over multiple experiences to an
instance of somebody making a fire or
providing me with a valentine's gift of a
hand axe.
I'm just thinking now to the moment to
moment ways of making of sampling the
world and making sense of the world.
It's the case that in order to move, in
order to change the world, I have to
attenuate the precision afforded my
sensory information because if I didn't
do that, I would not be able to ignore
all the evidence that I am not currently
moving.
So the most beautiful example of this, I
think, is something called sacanic
suppression.
It's when we move our eyes, and we do so
about four times a second, we actually
attenuate the precision of the sensory
evidence so that we are able to actually
move our eyes, which basically means you
can't see the optic flow induced when you
make a sharp or sacred eye movement.
And yet, 50 milliseconds after you've
made the eye movement, you're suddenly
now attending to the visual information
that you can see.
So you can't actually see anything while
your eyes are moving, because you've got
this sensory attenuation, which is
basically putting the priors in charge,
suspending attention to the sensorium
while you are acting, failures of that
can have quite horrible consequences.
So a failure to ignore the evidence that
I'm not moving and a failure to attenuate
or suspend attention attenuate the
precision of sensory evidence or afforded
sensory evidence, looks like things like
Parkinson's disease.
So we think that this precision is
encoded by certain neurochemical
transmitters, particularly dopamine.
A deficit of dopamine basically means an
inability to attenuate the evidence from
your strept receptors, all the signals
coming from the body that you're not
currently moving.
So if you have the pride belief, I'm
going to move, I'm going to sit up, walk,
drink from this cup, you may have that
prior belief, but it's immediately
counteracted by and dispelled by very
precise evidence that you're not moving.
So you can never actually initiate a
movement.
And what you actually see clinically is
basically a psychomotoptery or a brady
Kinesia.
The point I'm making here all reduces to
something very, very simple, which is the
precision afforded sensory evidence.
And if you can't get that right and
notice it has to be estimated at every
timescale, either in terms of sacredic
suppression on a ten millisecond
timescale, right through to, one might
actually argue, an evolutionary
timescale.
And I make that argument because
precision can also be thought of as a
rate constant.
So if I've got some sort of sensory
evidence and some prior beliefs, and I
now view my belief updating at any level,
whether it's sort of my neural activity
encoding my beliefs at the moment, or
whether it's my neuronal connectivity or
encoding what I have learned, or it's
neurodevelopment or indeed, at
evolutionary timescale, the precision can
be read as a rate constant.
So now what we're talking about is a
certain quantity that is absolutely
crucial for whether I adopt this or
incorporate instill this novel experience
into my model or not, that depends upon a
precision or a rate constant, which means
that if one wanted to ask the question,
why do some species have the ability to
learn whereas other species don't, then I
think the answer is, quite simply in
their ability to optimize and adjust
their learning rate.
Either precision afforded the evidence at
hand that drives the learning and I'm
wondering whether there are a couple of
ways to take that sort of mathematical
take on this really single, really
important quantity just to make it
intuitive.
I'm trying to get back to the copy versus
not copy.
So if I can copy, that means that I'm
impressionable.
What does that mean?
It means that I will accumulate new
evidence very very quickly.
What does that mean?
That means I have the capacity to assign
greater evidence or precision to that
sensory evidence and suspend the
precision of my prior beliefs.
I'm not rigid in my thinking.
I can learn because I am impressionable.
What would that look like?
What would it look like?
You were young.
It would look like you have just been
born and you are designed to learn
because you have yet to build
neurodevelopmentally your model of the
world.
Which means that averaged over a lifetime
the degree to which you are likely to
learn and implicitly enable the spread of
ideas and ignite this particular episode
of a new tool or a new way of doing
things or being then it would look as if
you are younger for longer.
So I was just intrigued.
I think Michael was making an explicit
reference to the fact that there may be a
key difference between certain species,
maybe the duration or the timing of the
point where you basically switch off your
learnability, you switch off your
impressionability, and you become an
adult and you bake in then.
And then from that point on, you become
old and wise and stuck in your ways.
And instead of actually trying to change
your mind when something changes, you
don't.
You become not conservative in a
political sense but you actually try to
keep things status quo, commit to the
social norms.
But before that you don't.
You explore, you go to discos, you do
bungee jumping, you make new friends.
But if it's the case then that the spread
of ideas depends upon being a child at
heart for longer than that observation
about at what point do we get to that
epigenetically determined stage of
neurodevelopment becomes absolutely
crucial and just.
This is the final point.
An even longer timescale I'm wondering
whether the same maths can be borrowed or
the same concepts at least can be
borrowed.
To think about this kind of evolvability
from the perspective of people like
Stuart Kaufman and the like.
So selection for selectability so again,
if you're now reading these rate
constants or precisions in an
evolutionary setting what you are talking
about is basically the mutation rates or
the selectability which of course itself
can be subject to selective pressure.
So if you commit to this style of
thinking about belief updating in a
mathematical sense at many different
levels or different spatial temporal
scales, or at least temporal scales, then
it may be that the selection for
selectability or the selectability in and
of itself is exactly the same kind of
quantity that is the learnability.
And being young at heart for longer, that
just is the same kind of quantity that is
required right down to the level of
psychiatric suppression and sensory
tennuation that determines when we act to
keep the world constant as opposed to no,
we actually have to attend to this
evidence and update our beliefs.
And if that's the case, then this notion
well, I just wanted to close on the
importance of cultural niche
construction.
Looked at through the lens of this rate
of adaptation.
Precision selectability at different
levels and how all of these couple to
each other in a sort of bootstrapping way
and whether that would be a useful view
of the spread of ideas sometimes
spreading and sometimes not spreading.
Can I just ask it did you laterally sort
of leverage sort of the well, actually
no.
This is basically setting up Daniel for
his perspective.
But I'm just wondering how much people in
evo devo and evolutionary psychology I'm
thinking here people like Cecilia Hayes
and cognitive Gadgets, how much they
think about these issues and whether
there's the opportunity or whether they
have a snakes and matters like view of
things from the point of view of
evolutionary psychology.
And that's it.
That's all I have to say.
Thank you.
Daniel, your turn.
Daniel: Thank you.
Wow.
Barely know which side of that hand axe
to flake the multiscale learning is a
great point and perspective.
We can just imagine the extreme cases in
the total acceptance of sensory evidence
world then that thing defined by its
revisiting potentially infrequently of
characteristic states that thing ceases
to be that thing in that whether that's
seen in some positive light, a neutral
entanglement light or a dean like light
it will cease to be that thing because it
will have just simply informationally if
not biomaterially accepted the generative
processes in positions.
And then the other extreme case would be
no attention, see no evil, hear no evil.
And in that case the trajectory from
Bayesian mechanics perspective is
massive.
It's a trajectory with so much inertia
that it can't be moved and that sounds
like it would ever happen.
But in fact, when we heard from Hector
and Michael that upon seeing an
innovation, a great ape does not take up
that innovation, their prior on how to
accomplish a behavior outcome or even at
a higher order, some functional outcome
can be seen as massive.
The Bayesian physical inertia of their
top down prior dominates these
potentially sparse or nonlinearly related
cues coming up from the bottom.
So simply by not paying attention to the
bottom up cues, there is the imposition
of this top down mass.
And so that's a Bayesian mechanical way
to understand well, if we had no priors
at all, no prior, no problem, but then we
dissolve.
But if we have the Titanic prior, then
it's a fragile strategy.
And so if the niche were very simple and
unchanging, that may be locally an
adaptive strategy.
And on certain axes of phenotype where
there can be regularities, we do see
those kinds of strategies.
Like a bacterium that has selected to
live in a constant temperature geothermal
niche may come to entrench in its protein
structure and in its gene regulatory
networks and so on.
An embodiment that sharpens and sharpens
and sharpens its capacity to compete in
that regularity from a temperature
perspective and therefore at the
detriment of fitness in changing
environments.
So that's one aspect is seeing learning
as this multiscale synergetic and ongoing
renegotiation process of the updating
across multiple scales, some spatial
temporal scales of which there are no
problems with talking about those using
the cognitive ontology like perception,
cognition and action.
But then some scales, especially beyond
the physical mechanisms that those
cognitive ontological terms arose from,
it becomes like, well, what does it mean
for the population to pay attention to
something?
Or what does it mean for the niche to pay
attention to something?
So that was one angle on the rates and it
speaks to the importance of having
flexible and interoperable mathematics
and statistics and analysis frameworks.
So we can just qualitatively, even in
conversation, start to see that as a
starting point, instead of needing to
argue up to that point of that being
important, for example, in pursuit of
transdisciplinary, synthesis,
conceptually, epistemically or so that we
could explain, predict, design, control,
create, pragmatically.
How can we take that multiscale insight
as our starting point?
And then I think that leads to a question
in the chat which I will ask now.
Mark Fruchman wrote early in the video
was the complaint that there was a lack
of evidence as to why certain things
occurred in the archaeological evidence
record?
How does active inference not suffer from
the same issue?
And so it's a key question.
Thank you, Mark, for asking.
And was the motivation for one of my
underlying motivations for even reading
and investigating with this lens was
great.
If we can describe everything and we have
this very interesting mathematics and so
on, how do we go from a technique and a
method to moving beyond some limitations
of previous analysis techniques with
respect especially to the historical
record?
We can go to Dean or whomever else has a
thought.
Dean: I can throw something in, but I'm
not sure it's going to satisfy directly
the question.
Maybe somebody else wants to throw
something in.
Karl: But.
Dean: I want to indirectly answer the
question and I'll loop into what I think
might be satisfying part of it.
I think one of the things that in
particular that to copy or not to copy
paper emphasizes is the observer's
perspective.
So rather than just looking at that as
something written down on the page,
taking up or absorbing that position, the
observer's perspective, I think what the
two papers.
And one of the things that we tried to
highlight, and we're so grateful that
Michael and Karl and Hector Beren
Millidge to let us look at two things at
once was the idea that the papers both
raised the specter of and I put quotes
around this.
The narrative follows what the
implications of start with a story about
seeing phenomena x actually are.
Now, one of the implications of that is
that when you have a story, you can't
have gaps in the plot.
So people who are really story biased and
story forward, they want those gaps
filled in as quickly as possible.
That's how we comprehend.
But the interesting thing is, if we are
actually active inference as opposed to
just seeing it as a subject matter or a
topic, we can take a game theory
approach.
And in games there will be random gas,
like Charles Saunders Pierce says, an
exhaustive inquiry.
Well, if it's exhaustive, we're also
going to need recovery and reflection and
so on.
So there will be gaps.
And so the snakes and ladders metaphor to
me is like, okay, perfect.
Now we're starting with a game as opposed
to the retelling or the manufacturing of
starting with a story.
So there's very different mechanisms in
the two approaches, right?
There are very different assumptions in
the two approaches.
And then the question around modeling as
perspective swapping kind of pivots on
the stuff that Michael was talking about
in terms of how is the change based
model, depth capacity either affording or
not affording that ability to play with
time as opposed to being captured by it?
Because in a story, you've written down
what the sequence is.
It's now been applied.
Now, you can interpret that, but in terms
of the actual effort of starting with a
story, it's now stabilized per se,
relatively speaking.
So let's start with a game.
And Karl's heard this before because I
asked him a question about a year and a
half, maybe two years ago.
Is starting with a game is a prediction
matter, expertise strategy or a bias?
Starting with a story is a subject
And you can understand why, if you're
dealing with historical records, to fall
into a default of, okay, well, we have to
start with a story.
But I think what Hector and Michael are
at least asking us to have a conversation
around is, well, so what if we do bring
this other way of viewing the
circumstances, taking that game strategy
and putting it on the same shelf as the
story strategy?
So, again, if you look at the assumptions
around why gaps have to be filled in as
opposed to there will be gaps because the
game is on something as simple as that.
And being able to hold the two things up
at once can sometimes at.
Michael: Least tell you a little bit
about.
Dean: Maybe some of the conditions that
you as the observer are.
Inserting on what it is that you're
observing or examining.
Daniel: Was it Sherlock who said, the
game is afoot?
Maybe?
Dean: Right.
Daniel: Okay.
Yes, Karl, indeed.
Michael or Hector, how is this landing
with what you're thinking right now?
Hector: Michael, go ahead.
You always know better than I can pick up
from you.
Michael: I'm not quite sure where to
begin.
Perhaps thinking in terms of the
evolution of both the brain and the body
in the Guinness homo we and possibly
neanderthals also maybe from as early as
three quarters of a million or even at
least half a million.
Years ago seem to have undergone an
evolution towards a bimodal growth spurt
or growth curve caused by the adolescent
growth spurt following a period of
childhood slowing down of growth which is
unique in organis and seems to be related
in adolescence to some changes in terms
of the agility to react to complex
situations or not, as the case may be.
But even before that, in early childhood
I'm now talking about the first three or
four years of life our infants seem to
have exceeded already quite considerably
their cognitive ability, particularly
with regard to working memory when
contrasted against the present great
apes.
In other words, there has definitely been
not merely an expansion of the brain but
in particular changes in the connective
systems within the brain which clearly
must have an evolutionary physical basis
in terms of structure, both inter and, in
particular, intra neuronal structure
which, when I began to study medicine
physiology over a long time ago now,
1960, we could barely imagine.
It was only in the very end of the 1950s,
I think 59, if I'm not mistaken,
Professor Friston Blanket, correct me,
that Cambridge Henry Huxley was doing
began to do into neuronal studies on
accident potentials.
We were doing them in the lab at Oxford
as undergraduates about four years
later.
And then I was doing them under Professor
Power gleece at gettingham a few years
later, still with a practical
application, because we were studying the
changes in these following
orthocryphosphate poisoning, which had a
structural situation in Hens, which we
were working on, similar to those in
humans who had suffered from a massive
outbreak of poisoning at Agadir in
Morocco when a lot of local people were
sold American jet fuel oil rich in
orthopesyl phosphates for cooking with.
And there was an epidemic of many deaths
which is well known in medical history.
And so some of these early studies, even
then, were having applications which now
seem almost paleolithic when we think of
the work which is being done on
interneuronal and also on synaptic
connectivity, neuronal transmission and
the effects not merely of genetics, such
as, for example, synaptic pooling, but
also of epigenetic modifications, which
no doubt we shall learn a lot more about
in the coming decades, but which even now
seem to be telling us that the increase
in the kind of connectivity or what's the
word I'm really looking for?
Perhaps connectivity is not the best word
within.
The brain is far greater than anything
which is possible within even growing
chimpanzees, let alone the adults or
other great apes.
And this must have evolved somehow,
probably in relation to the appearance, I
suspect, of the slowing down of childhood
growth followed by the uniquely human
Homo adolescent growth spurt which was
completely absent one and a half million
years ago in early Homo erectus,
according to Professor Christopher Dean
and others.
And which must surely have been a
response or the evolutionary change must
have been a response to not merely some
kind of magical physiological change, but
more likely to the effects of what one
might call behavior responses.
And fundamentally it takes us back to
active inference and to fundamental
changes which are naturally slow to
evolve.
And this is the part which is not
recognized by most of our colleagues who
work with living organisms, on living
climates and for that matter, living
human communities and individuals.
Their perspective is not that I hope
they'll forgive me for saying this which
those of us who've been brought up in the
natural sciences naturally come to
expect.
They don't have the kind of cosmic
timescale and cosmic spatial scale of
things and of the slowness and the
imperceptibility of change which come
naturally to those of us brought up from
school days in a different tradition.
And I think this is very important
because I think there is a big divide
still between what 60 years ago we knew
as being named the two cultures.
I think this divide still exists as that
critic of our paper who claimed we were
postmodernists clearly represents the
more, shall we say, intuitive
relativistic view in which there is
something which some of them believe to
want to call an ethnographical pleasant,
which I think is a contradiction in
terms.
Otherwise there could have been no
evolution in behavior.
But which wants to compare instead of
contrast, as I would have it, what goes
on in a few generations, let's say in a
community, be it a small one, albeit a
large one today, with what went on over
many, many generations.
As I said, between 2,200,000 years ago,
there would have been at least 80,000
generations if each was 25 years long.
And even that is pushing it a bit, given
that adulthood in Homo erectus was very
likely achieved before the age of 15 and
reproductive success was probably or the
next generation was probably only a few
years away.
This is important because, as Professor
Christian remarked talking about cancer,
our longevity has allowed us to and of
course on better hygiene and medical
knowledge, but particularly our longevity
has permitted us to survive in ways that
were unthinkable perhaps in many parts of
the world barely, well, less than 100
years ago.
It wasn't merely thanks to antibiotics or
even better hygiene, but to increases in
standard of living going back perhaps
perhaps a few hundred years.
But let's not get into that.
What I really want to say is.
Karl: That.
Michael: Next week I have to have a small
basal cell neoplasm removed from the side
of my nose, which only at the age of 80
or 81 became noticeable, indicating that
some of these diseases which we now
regard as being part and parcel of our
humanity.
Or the aortic stenosis, which was I was
diagnosed with my first and only ever
incident of cardiac failure about a year
ago and has been successfully treated
thanks to our modern catheterization
processes that allow prosthetes to be
prosthetics to be placed on heart valves
by a long catheter from the groin.
This kind of thing would have been
unthinkable a few years ago.
In fact, I can remember as an
undergraduate, as a medical student
watching the first ever open heart
operations done by Alf Gunning which was
regarded in 1960, wherever it was 63 64
as being something that might never might
never succeed.
And nowadays these operations on our
heart are just regarded as everyday
occurs in cardiovascular units around the
world things are changing and they're
changing with an acceleration which we
can only barely appreciate even those of
us who've now outlived our four school
years and ten and are on the verge of
defunction.
However, we have to think in terms of the
and this again is important of the
exponential, if you like, rather crudely
scale at which things are happening and
which are so influencing many people,
many of our colleagues in the humanities
and in the social studies and in indeed
studies of animal behavior, including
climate behavior of course.
And this I think is detracting from an
appreciation of the long time scale and
the over which evolutionary processes
have necessarily still take place.
I don't believe in gerdschmidt's hopeful
monsters, magical genes some people
believe that there's a magical gene in
Homo sapiens switched on our cognitive
ability.
I think this is wishful thinking.
Indeed it's magical thinking in my view.
However, I suppose my own training would
lead me to want to say that.
But there have been exceptions and one
exception I should like to mention by
name is an emeritus professor of
archaeology who is eminent in Paleolithic
studies at York University.
Now Professor Jeff Bailey who over 40
years ago was pointing out the
incommensurability of the timescales of
recent archaeology and if you like,
ethnography with those of the Paleolithic
and the Pleistocene and human evolution
and this was not really well regarded at
the time although it influenced me very
greatly.
There have been honorable exceptions who
have certainly influenced me.
We do, as I say, stand on the shoulders
of others.
We try to make one or two small comments
advances in both methodology and in
theoretical influences and deductions and
I think that we are finally coming to
possibly begin to see how to bring
together thanks to especially Professor
Friston's insights and methodological
what I'm trying to say, methodological
proposals and advances.
We're going to see that it might be
possible to square the circle, to bring
together the evolutionary, very slow
evolutionary development of the
hierarchical mind which characterizes our
Guinness and actual processes which can
underpin this undergird.
It can bring together the Darwinian view
which most of us espouse in the west with
a few exceptions, which are too well
known to be worth mentioning here.
I'm sure Daniel knows more about them
than I do.
But it's beginning to bring together the
theory of evolution of species by natural
selection of and within species and the
within part is important and it's
beginning to bring it together with what
we can appreciate about human behavior
which is so different from that of the
great apes.
And here I just like to make one final
point, which is that in another paper,
which Hector and I were co authors, along
with Professor Wright Reed of UCLA in
Neuroscience and Bio Behavior Reviews
last year, we pointed out that there has
been too much, in our view, hopeful or
wishful thinking about the human nature
of great apes.
Certainly their behavior is very
different from that of many other orders
of mammals and not to mention other
phyla, other classes.
Within the animal kingdom.
However, there is a big difference.
And I think this difference is best
emphasized by going back to the growth
curve of humans and of human behavior in
relation to our childhood.
In particular, our infants are capable by
about the age of three of putting of
combinatorial thinking in ways that are
virtually impossible or outside the scope
of the behavior of most great apes most
of the time and almost certainly in the
wild.
And this, I think, demands an explanation
which is more than simply saying no, the
apes are really more like us, it's just
that we don't recognize this.
No, I think that there is a difference
here and that the timescale has to be
taken into consideration, which it often
is not.
And most important and this brings me
back to my last point and the first one
which is that finally we're beginning to
get together thanks to Professor
Christensen's insights to seeing the
possibility of tying together the
biological evolution and if you like, the
psychological evolution.
Certainly I would say the neurobiological
evolution which has characterized Algenus
and characterizes it today in a unique
way.
And with that, that's my case.
Daniel: Thank you, Michael.
Many ways to go.
The dinner plate balanced on top of the
stick.
And I think that's the cognitive moment
where the top down constraints and
opportunities of our enabling
architectures, which for a long time
included primarily what was on board and
then over the last several thousand years
progressively included niche
modifications and stigmaic modifications
like writing.
And so, just like in the SPM toolkit for
studying brain function, there are brain
regions that have statistical connections
that aren't necessarily anatomically
connected and vice versa.
And when we consider information spaces
we have similar connectivity patterns.
Some are like information anatomy and
some are more like information physiology
in narrative or rhetorical spaces that
becomes part of our extended cognitive
selves and leave to others in the best
possible way those who want bright lines
of what is a self.
There are analytic frameworks that
respect continuities and discontinuities
with an emphasis on the respect, the
continuities.
We want them to be differentiable and
integrated and generalized coordinates of
motion and the continuous time active
inference models and the path integral
formulation and then the discrete time
generative model, which is also a map,
not the territory, helps us understand
saltatory maneuvers over multiple
timescales.
And looking back at the literature and
the discourse discussions like well, is
evolution gradual or general and
jumping?
These have been some of the biggest touch
points.
Are things slowly changing or fast
changing?
Those are where certain lines were drawn
and the methodological developments,
Bayesian graphs and so on and so on have
provided an instrumentalist lens that as
a matter of fact does integrate these
frameworks methodologically.
That is a claim that hardly anyone
dissents from.
And then what happens with respect to our
past, present and future when we realize
that we're, after the moment of intra and
among disciplinary tension, not pushing
the rock up the hill anymore or trying to
bring somebody else along, but gardening
in a space that already is how we need it
to be?
Michael: Could I make a comment?
Anil, Seth just occurred to me that when
we think of the formant frequencies that
affect all of the harmonics and other
aspects of our vocalizations whether
speech, chanting, song or even whistling,
perhaps it is unlikely or improbable that
these very many variants which occur in
different languages throughout the world
with their very, very different
characteristics and which almost
certainly Dean had begun to evolve quite
considerably by the time that earlier
writing appears about 5000 years ago.
But it's still unlikely that these can be
taken back into the past on a slow
evolving timescale such that they can be
related directly in a direct evolutionary
line to the vocalizations, let us say, of
great apes from a common ancestor that we
have with them 6 million years ago.
If we accept this unlikelihood, then it
seems equally unlikely to me that we can
talk about cultural transmission or
technological transmission in a slow,
uniform manner, invariant manner, over
the past, let's say, 2 million years,
from which we have information about
different technical skills and technical
abilities or at least, shall we say,
technical possibilities that were
exploited by our Guinness homo.
And therefore I would argue that it is
equally likely that the unawareness of
what people, what individuals were
actually enacting the unawareness by
bystanders onlookers, or even the very
protagonist protagonists of those
activities themselves was a continuous,
incontinenuous evolution over, let us
say, 80 or at least 60,000 generations in
a continuous, invariant manner.
This seems unlikely, and it seems equally
unlikely that the same is true of
different linguistic, shall we say,
abilities or aptitudes.
In other words, as Professor Christensen
has remarked in more than one paper, it
does seem that the advantages that were
taken were taken not in a continuous
manner, but in a discontinuous manner
when particular communicative skills had
developed.
In some groups, such as to be able to
widen their social scope for active
inference and had evolved by natural
selection within a shared framework of
adaptive prior beliefs favoring alignment
of common expectations and joint
activities affecting their ecological
niche, formation or development.
And this, it seems to me, is a very
expedient way of looking at how things
happened or likely to have happened.
Whether we will ever be able to produce a
theoretic in terms terms of formal
Bayesian proposal for this, I don't
know.
I would like to think so, but I really
don't know how.
I don't have the competence to begin to
do this myself, but I think that if it is
possible, it will certainly be, to put it
mildly, a challenge to those who tend to
think that there is a rapid jump or rapid
jump took place which, shall we say, a
small gap.
There's only a small gap that separates
us from the great apes of the equatorial
latitudes of the Old World.
I think that that took a much longer
period of time.
And I don't think that to compare what
modern even, shall we say, in inverted
commerce, relatively simple or primitive
communities do, or how they act, is
commensurable with the behavior of modern
great apes.
Frankly, I would like to challenge this,
and I would hope that it might be
possible to produce a model which will
permit the theoretic, which will permit
the evolutionary process to be at least
interpreted in an alternative fashion.
Sorry, I didn't mean to be long winded.
I apologize.
Daniel: The classical information is
inscribed on the holograph in the
classical sedimentary layers is Daniel,
you're muted.
Sorry.
In the holograph, we have the inscription
of the classical information and the
quantum cognitive moment is the unpacking
or the rotation of what is on the
holograph into the information space.
And that, I think, was provocatively
raised when you asked, what if this was
all there ever was?
What if there wasn't a second hand axe to
find at that field site?
That's the interpretive moment and how we
interpret it is everything.
So in our final ten minutes of this
continuous 53.1, if each of us could
provide a kind of closing just several
minutes, or any several thoughts on
anything they'd like to add into this
session, or any directions that they
would like to seed or prompt for next
week's 53.2.
Hector: I have something, Daniel, that we
like to contribute before we close the
session.
I would like to take advantage of
Professor Friston with us because I have
some questions for him that have to do
with the free energy principle and the to
copy and not to copy, if you allow me to
just formulate it.
And first thing I would like to do is
that there were some losses in my
argumentation before.
I want to make clear that chimpanzees
learn socially.
This is something we know for sure.
So there is social learning and there is
even cultures, as Professor Andrew Witten
in St.
Andrews has proven, has demonstrated.
So there are some cultural tradition.
What is lacking is accumulation of
complexity.
What is called by Michael Tomasello
ratcheting up.
Okay?
So from one generation to the next, every
generation builds upon what was produced
in last generation.
So you have a tool implement and you
modify it, you make it more complex.
So our technology is the result of many
people accumulating their knowledge.
So it's kind of a joint endeavor.
This I wanted to make clear.
And what the models proposed, theoretical
and other kind of models, is that copying
with fidelity is key to have this
accuracy of complexity.
So what I wanted to correct is that the
puzzle is that high rates of
innovativeness does not relate in an
action of complex technology because
there is a lack of copying with fidelity
what is called true imitation for some
and for Bruce and ambient, I think they
call it impersonation.
So I see someone doing something, I copy
the means and the result.
So chimpanzees are more prompted or
likely to emulate, which is copying the
end result, but by their own devices so
they can do different things to produce
the same result.
And it appears that coping with fidelity
is key.
And I'm cutting this long explanation.
I just wanted to correct this for the
sake of purity of science.
And now my question for Professor
Friston, if you allow me.
There is something interesting that the
team of Andrea Wheaton in St.
Andrews observed and that is in our
paper, that there was one instance that I
know of when there was this kind of
accumulation of complexity in
chimpanzees.
And the thing was possible because these
chimpanzees that combined two different
techniques to make something more
complex, we could be a kind of
primigenous example of what we call this
action of ratcheting up of behavior.
They did it because they had performed or
enacted these behaviors before.
And this is for me it's very intriguing
because thinking of how in 2010 there is
this paper by Priest and other people
where they talk of the generative models
under the free energy principle.
They talk of an active inference like
generative model are not a structural
representation, nothing that you enact.
You enter with your whole body, so to
speak.
Correct me if I'm wrong, Professor
Friston.
So I'm thinking that these guys, these
impulses that were able to have this
complex tool product, they had enacted
the behaviors independently before.
So I'm wondering if this enacting the
behavior before allowed them to overcome
surprise health because this would be
would go to the core of this idea of an
active inference.
Like if you have performed those things
separately with your body then the
surprise is kind of bounded and you can
produce this more complex product.
I mean, I don't know if that was clear
enough but this is something that is
intriguing to me.
Daniel: Sure Karl, as your last thoughts,
feel free to address that or anything
else.
Karl: Well, yes, I'm just reflecting on
that, I think very important question.
I mean it is certainly the case that all
of the active inference formalism both in
neuroscience but also in terms of
ensemble dynamics and self organization
of collections of things rests upon a
generative model of the consequences of
my action.
Even to the extent you could argue from a
telogical perspective that all our
perception is just in service of deciding
what's the best thing to do next and
literally how to move next.
Just acknowledging there are only a very
limited number of ways you can actually
change the universe.
You can either move a striated muscle or
you can secrete something.
There's not much else you can do.
And so it becomes very important in terms
of your characteristic state of being and
to have the right generative models that
choose the right ways to move your
muscles or to secrete things.
And that places embodied action or having
embodiment and activism at the center of
the generative models.
And it certainly makes sense to me from
the point of view of both a statistician
and a machine learning enthusiast that it
would be much easier to revise or update
a generative model in the sense you were
intimating in terms of accommodating the
next kind of behavior.
I'm not sure whether this was composing a
sequence of behaviors but certainly being
able to incrementally, embellish or adopt
a behavior if you had already a precursor
that was inherent in the structure or
could be scaffolded within your
generative model.
So the idea here is that everything that
goes on on the outside has to be in some
structural and dynamic way recapitulated
on the inside in order for you to control
the outside.
And this of course is at the heart of
early formulations of things like the
free free energy principle.
Cybernetics Roshbi's Good Regulator
theorem would say literally that and
subsequent formulations in terms of laws
of requisite variety that the degrees of
freedom on the inside have to correspond
to the degrees of freedom on the things
on the outside that have to be
controlled, namely the environment.
So I think that's absolutely right.
That if you had already established
through having an internal model of a
particular behavior, a particular way of
deploying my actuators and making sense
of that and being able to infer, it was
me that did that and this.
Is me doing that and this is the kind of
thing that I do then you are in a much
stronger position to learn or incorporate
or to imitate something that you have
witnessed novo and mathematically, the
reason why that becomes easier is that
the cost of belief updating in its most
general mathematical sense.
So I'm not talking about personal
beliefs, I'm just talking about any
belief entailed by the structure, the
connectivity, the activity, or indeed
say, neural activity.
Any belief updating comes along with a
cost.
And that cost can be variously
articulated in terms of a failure to
generalize informationally.
Thermodynamically it has a cost via
Landauer's principle.
But mathematically it's interesting that
the cost is the relative entropy between
your prior and posterior beliefs.
So this will be like a computational
cost, a complexity cost.
What that means is to make these steps,
be they gradual or be they big jumps,
they can only be made if they're, to use
one of your words, if they are suitably
bounded in terms of the complexity,
cost.
Which means the degree of belief updating
literally, the relative entropy or the
chaos divergence between the implicit
posterior and prior after the update is
sufficiently small.
Which means, literally, you're changing
your mind in a sort of mathematical
sense, in the most efficient way
possible.
So if you're already close to and have
the right kind of generative model to do
imitation of a de novo behavior in virtue
of the fact you've done it before, that
means that the complexity cost of
actually committing to that and revising
and belief updating your generative model
now becomes within a tenable range, it
becomes acceptable.
So that would certainly make sense if I
were simulating that.
And we've been talking about ways of all
sorts of different questions, the
questions in the chat Dean's questions
and the plea from Michael, how would you
make this mechanics work in terms of
resolving various hypotheses and evincing
insights into how all of this works?
I think at the end of the day you're
going to have to simulate it.
And this has not been done very much in
the setting of the free energy principle
or active inference certainly, but there
now are a number of papers coming out
within the past year or a few months and
it might be interesting to go to those.
And I'm thinking of, for example, a paper
by Casper Hest group that looked I think
the final write up is something like One
Small Step for Mankind or something, but
it was originally entitled Ideas Worth
Spreading.
So it's explicitly using the basic
mechanics of belief updating to look at
how spreadable, how copyable certain
beliefs were framed in the, in the
current age of the internet and sort of
tweets and the like.
And the same kind of theme has also been
taken up by colleagues of Conor Hines and
Maxwell Ransted in terms of simulating
epistemic communities where coming back
to Michael's use of the importance of
epistemic spread and copying and
imitation being basically an epistemic
spread that's now starting to be
simulated.
So I think we are on the cusp in the
world of active inference, at least on
having mechanics out there that's
actually realized in silicon that you can
start to intervene on a model, things of
this kind or that kind.
And speaking to Dean's question earlier
on, it strikes me that people in
Climatology must face exactly the same
problem.
Is this missing data or did this thing
actually go away?
And of course, it's a really important
question to answer that.
In principle, you can do it if you've got
a model of those legacy data, but you
have to have a model, which means you got
to basically have an in silico sort of
digital twin of the way you think it
works.
And then you can compare two generative
models or digital twins on the way it
works and see which has the greatest
evidence in light of the historical data
that clearly hasn't been done either in
climate change or or your field.
But in principle, that would be the way
to do that.
I'm sorry.
I've gone over time.
Sorry.
Daniel: It's totally fine.
My reflection on that again, anyone else
who wants to have any last words is in
the Par et al.
2022 textbook.
There is attention to two kinds of
surprise plain surprise, which is an
information theoretic quality quantity
associated with an observation with
respect to its prior, and the second
being Bayesian surprise, which is what
you just described the cost of movement,
which is related to the divergence of
movement.
And I think in that difference between
that was surprising and I surprised me or
I have changed, are two aspects of the
scenario.
Because to just be surprised doesn't
require one to change at all.
One can just say every day, wake up,
check the news, I can't believe that
they're doing that.
You can just be surprised again and
again.
And then there's the Bayesian surprise
with the belief updating.
And that is really where the semantic
advances of the Bayesian mechanics are
just beginning to mature.
Dean: I hate the last word, but I hope it
isn't so.
The provocations have been dropped in 530
and 53 one, and Daniel and Dean have
avoided being provocateurs so far.
What I'm really looking forward to is in
53.2 whether we can declare game on,
because I think if we do, if we have that
to look forward to, we can push the
narrative to the end of the timetable and
we can start to continue to enhance the
conversation that we initiated today.
So I just want to say thank you to all of
you for all of the care and passion that
you shared with us.
And I'm just happy as can be.
Michael: So thank you.
Daniel: Thank you.
Any final comments?
Hector or Michael?
Hector: No, just thank you for having us
and sharing this time with us.
It was been great discussion.
Thank you.
Michael: Well, thank you very much.
It's been.
Most profitable session.
Daniel: Excellent.
Karl, any last thoughts?
Karl: Again, I've enjoyed it greatly.
It's a real pleasure to actually speak to
all of you, but in particular, Michael
and Hector.
You're actually using words, spoken
words, very embodied, very active.
Lovely.
Daniel: Excellent.
All right.
Till next time.
Thank you, everybody.
Michael: Bye.